Vous avez déjà entendu parler de l'île
de Pâques et de ses curieuses statues?
Cette île chilienne de 160 km2, perdue dans l'océan Pacifique,
fait l'objet de nombreuses théories.
Certaines sont plausibles
et d'autres complètement loufoques.
Mais comment ces statues de plusieurs
tonnes ont-elles été
amenées sur cette île?
À quoi servaient-elles?
Quelles sont les hypothèses et révélations
de ces dernières années sur le sujet?
Ensemble, nous allons enquêter
sur le mystère de l'île de Pâques.
Et pour vous raconter cette histoire
fascinante, je serai accompagné de Axolot,
qui parraine ce quatrième épisode.
Chères curieuses, chers curieux, bonjour.
Je suis très heureux de vous retrouver
avec Fabien pour vous parler
des curiosités de l'île de Pâques.
Vous allez voir, c'est passionnant.
Bienvenue dans cabinet Curiouz.
Depuis des centaines d'années,
l'île de Pâques est la source
de curiosité, de mythes
et de théories étonnantes.
Mais savez-vous pourquoi on
l'appelle l'île de Pâques?
Pas pour les œufs en chocolat, évidemment.
l'Île a été visitée pour la première fois
par le navigateur néerlandais
Jacob Roggeveen,
le 6 avril 1722, jour de Pâques.
C'est tout naturellement qu'elle a été
nommée l'île de Pâques et lorsqu'elle a
été découverte par les Européens,
elle comptait à peu près 4000 habitants.
Parenthèse pour dire que les explorateurs
ne découvrent pas une île,
au sens littéral du terme.
Ce serait très problématique de penser ça
par rapport aux habitants
natifs de l'endroit.
Et si cette île est si populaire,
c'est bien évidemment pour son patrimoine
archéologique incroyable
qui a sculpté sa notoriété.
L'Île détient plus de 800 statues connues
sous le nom de Moaï, des statues composées
de tuf et de basalte (des roches volcaniques).
Elles sont monumentales et mesurent
en moyenne quatre mètres de hauteur
et pèsent environ 13 tonnes.
Les plus lourdes atteignent 80 tonnes.
Ces géants de pierre,
qui auraient été conçus entre 1510
et 1645, sont pour la plupart érigés
sur des terrasses empierrés
nommées des Ahu.
D'ailleurs, les Moaï
ne sont pas que des têtes.
Ce sont des personnages
complets avec un corps.
C'est ce qui les rend encore
plus impressionnants.
À l'image des pyramides, pour l'Egypte,
ces colosses sont le symbole
de la Polynésie et nous font
rêver de par leurs mystères.
Chaque année, ce sont 100 000 personnes
qui mettent le pied sur l'île,
ébahis devant ces masses silencieuses.
Mais pourquoi ces statues
ont-elles été érigées?
Quels sont les mythes les plus fous?
les théories les plus réalistes?
Avant de répondre à toutes ces questions,
je voulais vous partager
un petit fun fact.
Parmi les centaines de Moaï que compte
l'île, un seul se trouve sous la mer,
à 20 mètres de profondeur.
Pourquoi?
En réalité, il s'agit d'une réplique
moderne qui avait été construite
pour un tournage et qui sert
aujourd'hui de récif artificiel.
Mais revenons-en à nos théories
sur l'existence de ces colosses.
Pour justifier leur présence,
il y a plusieurs hypothèses.
Tout d'abord, les statues sont tournées
vers l'intérieur des terres
et non vers la mer.
Il s'agissait donc peut-être de divinités
qui surveillaient l'île et ses habitants.
D'ailleurs, il s'avère que les Moaï
possédaient des yeux faits de corail
et de roches volcaniques,
ce qui peut coller à cette explication.
Mais récemment, en 2019,
des chercheurs de l'Université
de Californie auraient enfin percé
le secret des statues. Pendant cinq ans,
ils ont mené des fouilles dans la carrière
de Rano Raraku qui est à l'origine
de la grande majorité des Moaï
et dont le sol est très riche
en phosphore et en calcium.
Leurs analyses ont révélé des traces
de culture de bananes et de patates
douces, entre autres.
Ce qui veut dire que la carrière a non
seulement servi à fabriquer
des Moaï, mais aussi à faire
pousser des fruits et des légumes.
A partir de ce constat,
la théorie des chercheurs est la suivante:
la construction des statues aurait permis
de favoriser la fertilité des sols.
En effet, le processus d'extraction
des roches aurait permis de créer un sol
propice à la croissance des plantes.
D'après Sarah Sherwood,
co-auteur de l'étude,
les flux constants de petits fragments
de roche générés par le processus
d'exploitation a permis un système
de retour parfait d'eau,
d'engrais naturel et de nutriments.
Une fois érigés, les Moaï étaient
donc un symbole de fertilité
qui permettait de stimuler
la production agricole.
Mais certaines statues semblent avoir
des orientations ou des
dispositions différentes.
Certaines sont placées le long des côtes,
d'autres à l'intérieur des terres.
Cela a intrigué les scientifiques
et voici des explications proposées.
Robert di Napoli,
archéologue à l'Université d'Oregon,
explique que les Moaï ont été
placés près des sources d'eau.
Il faut savoir que cette île
est dépourvue de rivières.
L'eau est donc une ressource rare.
On suppose que ces colosses pouvaient
symboliser le contrôle politique
des ressources naturelles,
de bases, marines ou agricoles.
Des statues de plusieurs tonnes
pour marquer son territoire,
c'est impressionnant.
Mais comment ont elles été déplacées alors
que plusieurs d'entre elles
pesaient plus de 100 tonnes?
Une légende populaire dit
que les statues marchaient.
En réalité, il y a deux théories.
L'une d'entre elles explique
que les habitants auraient tiré
les statues par des cordes des deux côtés
et qu'elles avanceraient en dodelinant,
un peu comme lorsqu'on déplace
un frigo pendant un déménagement.
L'hypothèse a d'ailleurs été testée
en vrai, comme dans cette vidéo où 18
hommes ont suffi pour déplacer un Moaï de
4,5 tonnes en béton créé pour l'occasion.
C'est plutôt bluffant. Mais en réalité,
les vrais Moaï pesaient bien plus de 4,5
tonnes et étaient construits
dans une roche plus fragile que le béton.
En utilisant la technique de la corde,
les Moaï se seraient fragilisés.
Il semblerait donc que les habitants
auraient acheminé les géants de pierres sous
forme de blocs bruts plus résistants,
les transportant sur des rondins de bois
en position allongée, pour finalement
les tailler une fois posés à destination.
Le mystère reste néanmoins entier
en attendant que d'autres scientifiques
mettent leur pierre à l'édifice pour nous
apporter de nouvelles
clés de compréhension.
Pierre à l'édifice.
Sculpture.
Moi, j'aime bien.
Un mystère encore plus grand plane autour
du rango rango, une écriture ancienne
découverte sur des tablettes
de bois au 19e siècle.
Elle se compose de hiéroglyphes,
dont certains ressemblent
à des animaux ou des plantes.
De nombreux experts se sont penchés
sur ces signes pour tenter
de les déchiffrer, mais en vain.
Et aujourd'hui, plus aucun habitant
de l'île ne sait les lire.
J'ai une autre histoire
intéressante pour vous.
En 1868, le navigateur Richard Powell
emporta un Moaï de quatre tonnes
vers le Royaume-Uni pour l'offrir
à la reine Victoria.
Aujourd'hui, ce Moaï est exposé
au British Museum de Londres.
Mais en toute logique,
les habitants de l'île de Pâques
veulent récupérer ce qui leur revient.
Pour Camilo Mapu,
président de la communauté de l'île,
cette statue abrite l'esprit de leurs
ancêtres et n'a pas qu'une
simple valeur archéologique.
Les représentants du gouvernement chilien
ont donc proposé au British Museum de leur
fournir une réplique du Moaï en basalte,
s'ils ramenaient l'original sur l'île.
L'opération est toujours
en cours de négociation.
Mais, si dans quelques mois,
vous apprenez qu'une statue de 4 tonnes
voyage depuis Londres vers l'île
de Pâques, vous vous
souviendrez de cette vidéo.
Pour conclure, si l'île de Pâques nous a
livré une partie de ses secrets,
elle en garde encore beaucoup pour elle.
Mais au delà de sa dimension énigmatique,
elle abrite un phénomène culturel unique
au monde, ce qui lui vaut d'être inscrite
au patrimoine mondial
de l'Unesco depuis 1995.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu.
Dites-moi en commentaire ce que vous
pensez de ces théories et si jamais vous
êtes déjà allé par hasard sur cette île,
je serais très curieux
de lire vos réponses.
Merci à Axolot d'avoir
participé à ce quatrième épisode.
Je vous invite à faire une escale sur sa
chaîne pleine de curiosités
et de lieux secrets.
Vous avez le lien dans la description.
Si vous me connaissez pas,
je m'appelle toujours Fabien Olicard,
Ça ne change pas.
Merci à vous qui likez cette vidéo
et vous pouvez vous abonner à cette
chaîne si vous le souhaitez.
C'est gratuit.
Vous trouverez à côté deux autres épisodes
du cabinet Curiouz et
dans la description,
la liste de tous les épisodes déjà
parus avec une playlist dédiée.
Dans la description toujours,
vous trouverez un lien vers mon magazine
papier Curiouz que vous recevrez tous
les mois chez vous si vous le souhaitez.
Un magazine de 62 pages pour assouvir
la curiosité de votre cerveau.
Le lien dans la description vous permettra
de découvrir quelques articles
gratuitement pour voir
si ça vous plaît ou pas.
Prenez soin de vous!
A très bientôt.
Tchao!